if you were watching any of the coverage
from Minneapolis today about what
happened last night you know perfectly
well the what's happening on the streets
there no matter what it may look like
he's actually a quest for justice it's a
long overdue search for answers by
legitimately frustrated protesters who
if we're gonna be honest about it
have been oppressed for so long they can
no longer stand idle what you're seeing
in Minneapolis is democracy in its
purest form effectively it's a political
rally here was a representative seen
last night wait a second
you may be thinking that didn't look
like a political rally those people look
like looters they were smashing cash
registers with hammers to steal other
people's money well yes technically they
were doing that and yes as a factual
matter they were smashing the cash
registers because they had already
stolen everything else in the store so
no it doesn't look like conventional
political activism but before you judge
them keep in mind it could have been far
worse it's not like they were doing
something immoral like protesting
Gretchen Whitmer's coronavirus lockdowns
in Michigan that would have been a
different story
black people's right to protest is
secondary to white people's right to be
an armed protest with long guns
terrifying looking war weapons this is
how the protest of Floyd's death ended
up police in riot gear flooding the
streets with tear grass and shooting
rubber bullets into the crowd
another example of how this pandemic has
been a kind of backlight exposing all
the inequalities in American life that's
the mean that's going around right now
with the cops with the black kid on the
ground saying hello to the white guy in
camo with the ak-47 and the mask who was
protesting in Michigan that when it's
white people with guns and they're out
and they're angry and their faces with
cops didn't see any of that
everybody's civil he says if some people
are accorded the rights of citizenship
and other folks are just expected to be
obedient these folks in the state
capitol crammed with weapons and they
were treated with keep drugs oh you see
it's not at all like those fascists in
Michigan in Minneapolis there's a reason
people doing it a legitimate reason even
the cash register smashers
they were civilly smashing the cash
register so relax by the way the cash
registers deserved it anyway this joy
Reed suggests on MSNBC they're probably
European cash registers and therefore
complicit in oppression Europeans came
to this country to get away from being
subjects of the kings in Europe but what
they did was they created for themselves
sort of a kingdom every man a king but
the subjects are black people these
armed white men who can get armed up and
walk into a state capital and that's
okay
and the police are benign they don't
even act afraid but let black people
show up and protest the death of an
innocent black man and suddenly you know
what we need tear gas we got to go full
force Charlotte's feel the same thing
the police were there to protect the
people who were marching as neo-nazis
not to protect the black people so who
watches joy read you may be wondering
well it turns out the people who run
Minneapolis apparently watched joy read
as their city crumbled around them local
leaders huddled in deliberation they
emerged with a plan they declared that
racism is quote a national emergency
CNN immediately trumpeted the
development as if it were breaking news
meanwhile mobs in downtown Minneapolis
kept looting stores kept burning normal
people of all colors huddled in doors
terrified no one bothered to explain how
any of this was connected how exactly
does racism have anything to do with
looting ATM machines or steel
Playstations from Target it's confusing
what we do know is that riots are now
acceptable because racism is a national
emergency that's the new standard okay
so now that we're in a state of national
emergency the question is what is not
acceptable what's not okay anything
here's what some of the quote protesters
were chanting last night in Minneapolis
so you're not gonna see that clip on CNN
how come it's simple facts like this and
there are a lot of them challenge the
carefully constructed storyline that our
leaders richly profit from therefore
those facts must be suppressed for
example practically every day we're told
that white cops are immortal threat to
black men and some are obviously it's
what started this whole thing a black
man was killed by the police it's awful
but one of the national numbers on this
well actually we know the answer
a study from last year found that white
police officers were less likely to
shoot and kill non 1.9 white suspects
then non-white police officers were in
any given year police kill more white
suspects armed and unarmed
then blasts black suspects and that's a
fact by the way it's not political
propaganda it's probably true you know
one on television will ever say that
because that fact threatens the scams
they're working any cloud Junior might
be the living embodiment of this
phenomenon if you've ever wondered
whether yelling racist at the people you
want things from is an effective
business plan any cloud is living proof
that indeed it is by regularly screaming
racist cloud has been able to ride a
mediocre academic career all the way to
an endowed professorship at Princeton
it's a job with such high pay and so few
actual requirements that GLAAD can dress
like a British Lord and spend much of
his day shuttling by limo between cable
news hits talk about a sweet gig as long
as Eddie globe continues to denounce
people as racist the right people he can
probably keep that job forever
so naturally Eddie Glade has no interest
in explaining how exactly racism makes
people loot target it just does okay and
if you disagree with that premise you're
a race
celsa shut up as loud told viewers at
MSNBC it's all about the quote context
as human beings natural inclination when
they feel wrong when they feel put upon
when they're living under best
conditions is to lash out and this is
the history of the modern West the
history of the world in actual in some
ways and so part of what we have to do
is try to understand the context that
led to what happened oh the context and
squinch arises at the context of course
there's a context as setting fire to
McDonalds says Professor cloud it's
interesting so you've got a wonder how
would Eddie Glau jr. respond if
something like this happened to him if
looters descended on his house would
glad gently describe them as protesters
as they made off with his amaze necktie
collection if thugs with bandanas on
their faces smashed the windshield of
his BMW with rocks would any glad call
the police or we're calling the police
be racist just how long in other words
could Eddie Glaude maintain his
fraudulent racial justice shtick in the
face of the kind of violence that he
routinely excuses on television we're
thinking not very long that's just a
guess let's hope Eddie glad he's never
tested on that certainly anytime soon
let's hope none of us are tested the
problem with outbreaks of mob violence
is you really have no idea where they're
going next you can't know sometimes they
subside often they metastasize they are
unpredictable and they are mortally
dangerous and that's why you don't
encourage them in st. Paul signs have
appeared in store windows announcing
this is a black owned business in other
words we're the right skin color spare
us what does that tell you imagine if
you saw a sign saying white owned
business in Windows you would be
horrified and you should be you'd know
it was a race riot we've had a lot of
those in this country through the years
and there is nothing worse than that but
Minneapolis has decided to just let
their riot happen and damn the
consequences watch the city's police
chief explained why he doesn't plan to
do anything at all to stop rioters so
what you're saying is it's too dangerous
for police to directly confront the
looters so you've made the decision to
maybe let that site go for now and focus
on keeping the rest of the neighborhood
as safe as possible
capsule er officers are being have been
through several hours here Molotov
cocktails - don't ask them rocks and
other projectiles and so obviously their
safety is paramount and so I don't want
them going into an area where they're at
risk of harm themselves obviously the
safety of officers is paramount
announces that chief the interviewer
says nothing but in fact that's not at
all obvious in fact it's perfectly
backward society's first concern is the
safety of citizens especially the
weakest citizens that's why we have
police in the first place to protect
people who cannot protect themselves the
public not everyone wants to do that job
and that's fine do something else but we
can't allow this
imagine if the Secret Service adopted
the same attitude sorry can't protect
the president today too risky how about
the military we'd love to repel the
invasion but unfortunately we might get
hurt our apologies things would fall
apart things are falling apart in
Minneapolis and as they collapse our
leadership class seems thrilled they're
doing nothing to calm racial division in
fact they're eagerly stoking it the New
York Times write a piece just this
morning with the title how white women
use themselves as instruments of Terror
the subhead read this way quote there
are too many noose necks charred bodies
and drowned Souls for them to deny
knowing precisely what they are doing
wait a second them what they are doing
keep in mind this didn't run in Louis
Farrakhan's
free weekly this was the New York Times
this country's most important newspaper
the high temple of American liberalism
the New York Times is telling you that
every single person of a certain color
and sex has a hand in genocide they are
stained by blood guilt they are
murderers every one of them what do you
do to murderers you know the answer it's
hard to believe our leaders are actually
talking like this but they are a lot and
loudly and if they keep it up things
will not end well
and yet they show no signs of slowing
down watches two of CNN's leading lights
get to the bottom of the national
emergency we're living through they've
discovered Hoosiers
constable for it 100% responsible they
know who's guilty here's a hint it's an
entire racial group it is not incumbent
upon black people to stop racism to stop
this it is incumbent upon people who
hold the power in this society to help
to do that
to do the heavy lifting and guess who
that is who is that Chris white people
the funny thing is as we often point out
these are the very same people who claim
they're fighting your racism okay but
the problem is much bigger this time
than mere hypocrisy we're very used to
that this problem is far more ominous
here it is in three sentences there are
three hundred and twenty million of us
in this country a lot of us are very
different from one another yet we all
have to live together in fact most of us
want to live together but suddenly our
leaders are making that dangerously
difficult